This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个I-Heart播客。百分之二。这是指在有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目“百分之二”中，我将剖析我们这个光怪陆离的现代世界中，精神坚韧、体能锻炼以及培养适应力的种种迹象。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难险阻，你就会浴火重生，成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。收听“百分之二”。请在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方搜索“2%”。在《Look Back at it》播客中。从1979年开始，这对我是个重要时刻。84年对我也很重要。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·恩格利什。每期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。与我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及最喜爱的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。1984年是疯狂的一年。真是疯狂的一年。我觉得对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. does not mean that you need to.
请在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，各位最近怎么样？欢迎收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·加姆斯。这个空间聚焦黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都极其不安全的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一个懂行的执照专业人士进行交流。有多少男人穿着一套精神铠甲。它向世界发出信号：你可不是好惹的。但这并不意味着仅仅因为你有这种能力。你。就非得这么做不可。
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Hello and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, a very unprofessional podcast whereby I your unqualified guide, talk through some of the big changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Okay, so welcome back. I'm recording this episode in my car, in my backyard today. just because do you know how it is lockdown all my housemates are home i don't really want to annoy them with my ranting about this week's topic it also means if you hear like some beautiful
请在iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。大家好，欢迎回到《你的二十多岁心理学》，这是一个非常不专业的播客，作为你们不合格的向导，我将和大家一起探讨我们在二十多岁时遇到的一些重大变化与人生过渡，以及它们对我们心理的意义。好了，欢迎回来。我今天是在后院的车里录制这期节目。只是因为——你知道的，封城期间我所有的室友都在家，我实在不想因为自己对本周话题的夸夸其谈而惹恼他们这也意味着如果你听到一些美妙的。
bird noises hopefully it brings something to the ambience it's very snow white esk okay let's get into it so this episode is probably my absolute favorite i have ever recorded and don't get me wrong i really have loved all the other topics that I've covered. But I think that none have kind of struck me so personally as this one. It's really hit a bit of a raw nerve, honestly, like researching this, thinking about this, because currently, if you don't know, Gambra is in lockdown due to the Delta strain as many parts of Australia. Thanks, Sydney, for that one. But as much as it has, you know, created some existential dread, it's also given me a lot of thinking time and reflection time. and something that I've been really thinking about a lot in this period of isolation is unrequited love.
鸟鸣声，希望它能增添一些氛围感，这非常白雪公主风。好吧，我们切入正题。所以这期节目可能是我录过的绝对最爱的一期，别误会，我真的很喜欢我之前聊过所有其他主题。但我认为，没有任何一个能像这个一样如此深深地触动我的个人情感。说实话，做这个研究、思考这个话题真的触及了我的痛处，因为目前，如果你还不知道的话，甘布拉和澳大利亚的许多地方一样，由于德尔塔变异株而处于封城状态。悉尼，谢谢你带给我们的这一切。但尽管它确实，你知道的，带来了一些生存焦虑，它也给了我很多思考和反思的时间。而我在这个隔离期间真正反复思考的一件事，就是单恋。
I posted about this on my Instagram, I think maybe like a week ago, and overwhelmingly people really wanted to hear about the psychological underpinnings of this experience. You know, a love that is unrequited and unreliated is such a universal and shared experience, and I think it's such a consuming one too. You know, it suffocates all else in our minds and it extends beyond reason and rationality in so many ways just by all acknowledgement that someone does not love you back. We cannot help but pine and suffer after them.
我在Instagram上发了关于这个的内容，我想大概是一周前吧，大家反响极其热烈，非常想听听这种经历背后的心理学基础。你知道，得不到回应和无法释怀的爱是一种如此普遍且共同的经历，而且我认为它也是一种极度消耗精力的经历。你知道的，它在我们的脑海中窒息了一切，并在许多方面超越了理智与理性——尽管我们完全承认对方并不爱我们。我们还是忍不住对他们朝思暮想、备受折磨。
And as a repeated victim of this love sick situation, I really kind of wanted to uncover some of the hidden psychological secrets maybe behind why we develop strong feelings for those who could never reciprocate those feelings back. Now I feel like I don't really need to explain how unrequited love relates to our 20s. Like that's not kid ourselves at Spotify. It gives me a little wrap-up of the ages or demographics of people who listen each week and overwhelmingly, as the title of my podcast could probably predict. The majority of you are in your 20s. And I'm, sure are very familiar with this feeling, that fucking gut-wrenching feeling of having these
作为这种恋爱脑受害者的常客，我真的很想揭开一些隐藏的心理学秘密，探寻我们为什么会对那些永远无法给予回应的人产生强烈的情感。现在我觉得我真的不需要解释单恋与我们的二十多岁有什么关系。就像我们别自欺欺人了，Spotify每周都会给我一个小总结，列出每周听众的年龄或人口统计数据，正如我播客的标题所能预料的那样，绝大多数听众都在二十多岁。而且我相信，你们对这种感觉一定非常熟悉——那种撕心裂肺的感觉：对一个永远、你知道的，永远不会回应你的人，怀有这种疯狂强烈的情感和期望。
insanely strong emotions and expectations of someone who will never, you know, could never return them. And the pain, the confusion of unrequited love, I think it is its own psychological challenge. And if, you know, you say you've never experienced unrequited love, well, firstly, this episode is not for your ears. Please kindly leave. This is a safe space. But secondly, I think I think you're probably lying to yourself. You know, I refuse to believe that there is someone out there who has only ever loved those who has loved them back in equal measure. It's impossible. Like psychology literally says it's impossible, which will obviously get to in a moment. Anyhow, like I mentioned, I've been thinking about unrequited love
单恋带来的痛苦和困惑，我认为它本身就是一种心理挑战。如果你，你知道的，说你从来没有经历过单恋，那么首先，这期节目可不是说给你的。请自行离开。这里是一个安全空间。但其次，我想——我想你可能是在对自己撒谎。你知道的，我拒绝相信世上会有人只爱过那些同样深深爱着自己的人。这不可能。就像心理学字面意义上说的，这绝无可能，我们稍后就会讨论到这一点。无论如何，正如我所提到的，我在封城期间一直在思考单恋。
quite a lot in this time of lockdown. You know, I kind of used to send me a joke that I came out of the room and a state of unrequited love. And I still slightly believe it. You know, it feels weird to share this insanely personal dimension of my life, but fuck it. I think it is a universal human experience that needs to be shared. And for a long time, unrequited love really did define much of the narrative I would tell about myself, you know, the men I was so in love with, so it had voted to so it had so much admiration for who would never reciprocate it was such and i think still is a fundamental part of my experience with with love or maybe my misguided interpretation of what it is i you know i don't really feel any shame in saying that especially through some
想得相当多。你知道的，我以前常开玩笑说，我是从失恋的状态中走出来的。而且我现在仍然有点相信这一点。你知道的，分享我生活中这个极其私密的维度感觉怪怪的，但管他呢。我认为这是一个需要被分享的普遍人类经历。很长一段时间里，单恋确实构成了我对自己叙事的大部分内容，你知道的，那些我深深爱着、如此投入、如此崇拜、却永远不会给我回应的男人，这曾是——而且我认为现在仍然是——我体验爱情的核心部分，或者说也许是我对爱是什么的误解。我，你知道的，说出这些并不觉得有什么羞耻，特别是通过我为这个播客所做的一些。
of my investigative work for this podcast i do think you know you never really escape the ego wound of loving someone who doesn't love you and there's a part of your soul and your self-conception that does not forget that hurt. It's a wound that really does cut deep into your psyche and it becomes ingrained into you and it does become part of how you address all future experiences of emotion and feeling because it's bigger than rejection.
调查工作，我确实认为，你知道的，你永远无法真正摆脱去爱一个不爱自己的人所受到的自我创伤，你灵魂和自我认知中总有一部分是不会忘记那种痛的。这个伤口确实深深地刺入了你的心理，并在你身上根深蒂固，它成为了你应对所有未来情绪和情感体验方式的一部分，因为它远超被拒绝的范畴。
You know, unrequited love is not just rejection. It's heartbreak itself and a lot of research into how our brain reacts to human connection really does confirm this. there have been so many people who I have believed, I have loved, and who have not loved me back. You know, one of them is even married now and there are times, especially in this recent week, strangely when, you know, I have had time to reflect on that emotional experience that I do feel these like strainedly old urges and the pain of longing kind of slip back into my consciousness, despite knowing very well that this is not something that will ever come to fruition.
你知道的，单恋不仅仅是被拒绝。它是心碎本身，许多关于我们的大脑如何对人类连接做出反应的研究确实证实了这一点。有那么多我曾以为我爱过、而他们却没有回爱我的人。你知道，其中一个人现在甚至已经结婚了，有时，特别是在最近这周，奇怪的是，当我有时间反思那种情感经历时，我确实感觉到这些极其奇怪的旧冲动和渴望的痛苦悄悄溜回了我的意识中，尽管我很清楚这绝不会有什么结果。
You know, he's married. Like, it's never going to happen. So why is it that our brain reacts so irrationally when we are confronted with these feelings and expectations? And what I really wanted to find out in this episode is if that is really love, like all those intense emotional experiences, are we correct in labelling them as love, even unrequited love or love of a lesser degree? So like I said, a highly personal episode. but I think I've always said this podcast was for my own self-exploration and if you get something out of it, if you connect to my stories of, you know, always being the one who has
你知道的，他结婚了。所以这永远不可能发生。那么，为什么当我们面对这些情感和期望时，我们的大脑会做出如此不理智的反应呢？在这期节目中，我真正想弄清楚的是，这真的是爱吗，就像所有那些强烈的情感体验一样，我们将它们贴上“爱”的标签是对的吗，哪怕是单恋或是程度较低的爱？所以就像我说的，这是一期非常私人的节目。但我认为我一直都说过，这个播客是为了我自己的自我探索，如果你能从中获得收获，如果你能与我的故事产生共鸣——你知道的，总是那个付出比收到的。
more to give than I could ever receive. I'm glad that you can get something out of it. And I feel like I've talked to my friends about this so often, you know, this is probably time for an immense shout out to my friends like Kate and Aaron, friends of the show who I think for years have witnessed me becoming overly invested. in silly little men and then crying on their shoulder a month later, but I always hear the same line of reasoning for this predicament. You know, it's always you love too much, you care too deeply, you see the best in everyone, you have so much to give.
更多的付出者。我很高兴你能从中有所收获。我觉得我和朋友们经常谈论这个，你知道的，现在可能是向我的朋友凯特和埃伦大声致谢的时候了，她们是节目的老朋友，我想她们多年来一直见证着我过度投入。到那些无聊的小男生身上，然后一个月后在他们的肩膀上哭泣。但我总是听到对这种困境的相同解释。你知道，总是说你爱得太多，你在乎得太深，你在每个人身上都看到最好的一面，你有太多的爱可以付出。
And this episode is really dedicated to erasing that myth that only those who have this surging capacity to feel end up in a predicament of unrequited love. Like make no mistake. unrequited love has an origin in our formative experiences and how we've been taught to expect rewards and returns from our expression of emotion and unrequited love can occur because our mind is simply hijacked or programmed to respond to what we interpret as love in a very specific way and beyond a level of consciousness so okay with that kind of fun thought in mind let's jump into
这期节目确实致力于打破这样一个神话：只有那些拥有激昂情感容量的人才会陷入单恋的困境。所以毫无疑问。单恋根源于我们的成型经历，根源于我们如何被教导去期望从情感表达中获得回报和反馈，而且单恋之所以会发生，是因为我们的心理被劫持或编程，以一种非常具体的方式对我们解读为爱的事物做出反应，并且超出了意识水平。所以好吧，带着这种有趣的思考，让我们深入探讨。
the psychology of it all I once had someone tell me me that unrequited love was the purest form of love. And despite that being kind of highly manipulative for the situation that we were in, this was years ago, like four or five years ago. And what he has said has stuck with me because his sentiment is absolutely everywhere. But whether it's correct is probably a whole other debate. You know, there's that quote that all poets must have an unrequited love and true love is that which we can never meet. And we see unrequited love showing up everywhere in pop culture and media performances. Movies, you know, call me by your name, Great Gatsby, obviously,
这一切背后的心理学。我曾经听人说过，单恋是最高纯度的爱。尽管对于我们当时的处境来说，这有点极具操控性，那是多年前的事了，大概四五年前吧。他所说的话一直深深印在我脑海中，因为这种观点简直无处不在。但它是否正确，可能完全是另一个争论了。你知道，有句名言说，所有的诗人都必须有一段单恋，真爱就是我们永远无法相遇的那种爱。我们在流行文化和媒体表演中到处都能看到单恋的身影。电影，你知道的，比如《请以你的名字呼唤我》、《了不起的盖茨比》，显而易见。
pokes of being a wallflower, even Forrest Gump. It is such a deep inspiration for a lot of creative works like music and art as well. And oh my gosh, there's that one, this one, one song that always gets me when I find myself in these situations as I regularly do. It's Adele's version of I Can't Make You Love Me. And if you are currently experiencing a love that is unrequired, unrequited, listen to that song, feel your pain and take it as a sign to move the fuck on. Because if you are listening to Adele, they are not the one.
《壁花少年》，甚至《阿甘正传》。它为许多音乐和艺术等创意作品提供了深刻的灵感。哦天哪，还有那一首，这一首，有一首歌每当我发现自己陷入这种境况时总是直戳我心，就像我经常做的那样。那是阿黛尔版本的《I Can't Make You Love Me》。如果你目前正在经历一段得不到回应的爱——单恋，去听听那首歌，去感受你的痛苦，并把它当作一个信号，赶紧麻溜地走人吧。因为如果你在听阿黛尔的歌，那说明他们根本就不是那个人。
Like, they are just not it. But in all seriousness, it is a really beautiful song. And I think the repeated theme of unrequited love across a lot of creative media really expresses two things that relate to the psychological underpinnings of this concept. You know, firstly, the experience is universal and has some innate premise that makes it so commonplace. You know, as I've kind of alluded to, everyone has experienced this. We all tend to make other people sacred. in the absence of true emotional connection.
就像，他们真的不是。但说真的，这真的是一首非常美妙的歌。我认为，单恋这一主题在许多创意媒体中的不断重复，实际上表达了与这一概念的心理学基础相关的两件事。你知道，首先，这种体验是普遍存在的，并且具有某种使其变得如此司空见惯的先天前提。正如我所暗示的，每个人都经历过这一切。在缺乏真正的精神连接时，我们往往会把其他人神圣化。
You know, placing someone on a pedestal is better than acknowledging that we have been short-sighted in essentially worshipping someone that's really not worth our time. I think very few of us can rationalise desire and can rationalise wanting someone who does not love or want you back. And I'll go more into this later, but a love that is unrequited is very much tied to our brain chemistry. It's tied to reinforcement and behaviourist theories as well as attachment style as well, which I think is often must, you know, really misunderstood, but does greatly contribute to this experience. And essentially, there are core aspects of the human psyche that inexplicably
你知道的，把某人放在神坛上，总好过承认我们在本质上是在崇拜一个根本不值得我们花时间的人，在这方面我们目光短浅。我想我们当中很少有人能理性地看待欲望，理性地去渴望一个不爱也不想要你的人。我稍后会对此进行更多探讨，但单恋与我们的大脑化学机制有着极大的联系。它与强化理论和行为主义理论有关，也与依恋类型有关，我认为依恋类型通常被大肆（误解），你知道的，确实对这种经历起到了很大的推波助澜作用。本质上，人类心理的核心方面存在着某些难以解释的因素。
lend themselves to experiencing unrequited love, even if it's, you know, from a distance. But, you know, I think, as I'm sure we all know, it's, it is often experience. for those who we do have somewhat of an emotional or pre-existing sexual or physical connection with. Secondly, from how this experience is portrayed, is as romantic and a powerful force, we can see that unrequited love is somewhat glorified by our society in kind of an unnecessary way. And I definitely want to talk more about why I find this interpretation so incorrect later on Because I think although we romanticise the suffering and grief of longing of not being loved back, it is actually a really fucking terrible feeling.
使自己倾向于经历单恋，即使这种单恋是，你知道的，从远处发生的。但是，你知道的，正如我们所知，它通常是经历过的。针对那些我们确实与之有某种情感、或预先存在的性或身体联系的人。其次，从这种经历的描绘方式来看，它被视为浪漫且强大的力量，我们可以看到我们的社会以某种不必要的方式将单恋浪漫化了。我绝对想在后面多谈谈为什么我发现这种解读是如此不正确，因为我认为尽管我们把渴望的痛苦和悲伤、以及不被回爱的痛苦浪漫化了，但这实际上是一种他妈的糟糕感觉。
And can we even call that love? You know, a feeling that is that painful in many ways, is it right to kind of combine that with something that is meant to be as beautiful as love? And I think the romanticisation of unrequited love also relates greatly to our glorification of things. that are beautiful, particularly art. And as that quote I cited before kind of captured, we have this preconception or idea that pain lends itself so fully to creative expression and feeling human in a way that few other emotional experiences let us do
我们甚至能称之为爱吗？你知道的，在许多方面都如此痛苦的感觉，把它和本应像爱一样美好的东西结合在一起，真的对吗？我认为单恋的浪漫化也极大地关系到我们对事物的颂扬。那些美好的事物，尤其是艺术。正如我之前引用的那句话所捕捉到的那样，我们有一种先入为主的观念或想法，即痛苦极大地促进了创造性的表达和人类情感的体验，这是其他少数情感体验所无法做到的。
and in much life grief and death. The absence of love is such a moving experience that we must glorify it because of what it produces artistically and creatively. But the pain and discomfort and discomfort of, you know, it's not something to be understated from a psychological perspective. That feeling of hurt that is associated with something deeper than rejection, it does cause long-term shifts in neural pathways, our schemers of the world, and how we learn to interpret people's actions, you know, as either threats or as encouragement.
就像生活中的悲伤和死亡一样。爱的缺失是一种如此触动人心的经历，以至于我们必须因为它的艺术和创意产出而颂扬它。但从心理学的角度来看，痛苦、不适和不适感，（这是）不容低估的。那种与比拒绝更深层次的东西联系在一起的受伤感，确实会导致神经回路、我们对世界的图式（schema），以及我们如何学会将人们的行为解读为威胁还是鼓励等方面发生长期的转变。
And before we dive into this, I do think we firstly need to talk about the origins of unrequited love. You know, I've mentioned that I do believe it's a universal experience, and it's often given this beautiful, you know, honey gold tint to it, longing for someone who may have no interest in you or maybe someone else, does seem really beautiful at face value. But then why do these feelings emerge if we know that they're a logical? and contradict how we may see ourselves as self-reliing and independent. You know, that's something I often find is I have these feelings of unrecognited love for someone.
在我们深入探讨之前，我认为我们首先需要讨论单恋的起源。你知道的，我提到过，我确实相信这是一种普遍的体验，它经常被涂上一层美丽的、蜂蜜金般的色彩，渴望一个可能对你毫无兴趣的人，或者可能对别人感兴趣的人，表面上看确实非常美好。但如果我们知道这些感觉是不合逻辑的，并且与我们如何看待自己是自主独立的人相矛盾，为什么这些感觉还会出现呢？你知道，我经常发现的是，我对某人产生了这种单恋的感觉。
I think I really care about them. You know, you can become obsessed with them. But at the same time, there's this contradictory voice in my head saying, you know, you don't need them. If they don't, you know, the phrase that my friend Aaron always uses is like the egg doesn't chase the sperm. Like if they don't like you back, that does create kind of a cognitive distance. with this sense that you're this independent person who will survive without them. Okay, I have a few theories around this, obviously, which is why I'm making this podcast,
我觉得我真的很在乎他们。你知道的，你会对他们着迷。但与此同时，我脑海中有一个矛盾的声音在说，你知道的，你不需要他们。如果他们不，你知道的，我的朋友埃伦总是用的那句话是：“卵子不会去追精子。”就像如果他们不喜欢你，这确实会产生一种认知失调。伴随着一种感觉：你是一个没有他们也能生存的独立个体。好吧，我对此有一些理论，显然这就是我制作这个播客的原因。
but firstly, unrequited love, it serves a purpose as an emotional curtain or a distraction from the real issues that we may be experiencing. You know, external to these feelings of desire, it can act as a substitute and a substitute emotional trial almost for the real underlying issues that are afflicting our ego. And I can definitely relate to this. I remember even recently an episode of love that was unrequited that I've been through with some guy I've been talking to for months and, you know, yeah, I started developing feelings for him. They obviously weren't reciprocated but there was some small part of my brain that was almost grateful I had this person to preoccupy
但首先，单恋，它起到了情感幕布或分心的作用，让我们从可能正在经历的真实问题中转移注意力。你知道，在这些欲望的感觉之外，它可以起到一种替代作用，几乎可以作为一种替代的情感审判，来应对折磨我们自我的真实潜在问题。我绝对能对此感同身受。我甚至记得就在最近，我经历了一段单恋插曲，和一个我聊了好几个月的家伙，然后，是的，我开始对他产生感情。它们显然没有得到回应，但我大脑中有一小部分几乎很庆幸我有这个人来占据。
my mind with because it meant that I could have a mental reprieve from thinking about the bigger issues that were going on. You know, I really remember it was almost like a conscious sigh of relief. Like, thank God you've come along and fucked with my feelings because now I can project all this other shit onto you and you can kind of be like a little thought vacation from the reality and then the past that I have to heal from. So if your mind is preoccupied with thoughts, of another person, admiration for them, and fantasies of, you know, what it could be like if your feelings were reciprocated as well as that emotional discomfort of the what-ifs. That is like the ultimate distraction from other aspects of your life that may be causing insecurity or
我的心思，这意味着我可以从思考正在发生更大问题的精神喘息中解脱出来。你知道，我真的记得那几乎就像是一声有意识的如释重负的叹息。就像，谢天谢地你出现了，把我的感情搞得一团糟，因为现在我可以把所有其他的狗屎都投射到你身上，你可以有点像是我对现实的一次思想度假，以及我必须从中疗愈的过去。所以，如果你的大脑被这些想法所占据，对另一个人的想法、对他们的崇拜、以及如果你的感情得到回报会是什么样子的幻想，还有那些“如果……”的情感不安。这就像是对你生活中可能导致不安全感或。
general unhappiness. You know, our brain and our mind is at all times looking towards self-preservation and investing your pain in someone else is an excellent distraction and allows your brain to move away from other persistent thought patterns, perhaps about past loves, in my case, that's what it was, or even aspects of your life that are entirely unrelated, you know, unrequited love for a short while does serve as a substitute or a distraction. Okay, but it's obviously, I think, more than just a coping mechanism for other aspects of your life that you might not be happy with. Another theory, which is a more learning base, theory suggests that these unresipicated feelings and this pattern of sinking deep into emotions
普遍不快乐的其他方面的终极干扰。你知道的，我们的大脑和心智在任何时候都在寻求自我保护，把你的痛苦投入到别人身上是一个极好的干扰，它能让你的大脑远离其他挥之不去的思维模式，也许是关于过去的爱情——在我的情况下就是这样，或者是甚至与此完全无关的生活方面，你知道的，单恋在短时间内确实起到了替代品或干扰的作用。好吧，但这显然不仅仅是对你不满意的人生的其他方面的一种应对机制。另一个理论，一个更加基于学习的理论表明，这些未得到回应的感情以及深深陷入。
for someone who's obviously unavailable comes from a pattern of past love, perhaps starting early in life that has taught you to crave what is being withdrawn and held back. And on the flip side, it makes you scared of love that is obvious and available. You don't simply fall for people because of an innate weakness or a personality characteristic, but because it is a pathological pattern of behaviour that you've been taught, especially from formative experiences, maybe like a first love, or from observing others like your parents or those around you. So this experience and seeing these things creates memory roots in your mind that are associated with a particular feeling or reaction. And in this scenario, a feeling that is akin to what we believe.
对一个明显不可及的人的情感模式，来自于过去的爱情模式，也许始于生命早期，它教会你去渴望那些被收回和保留的东西。而另一方面，它让你害怕那些显而易见且唾手可得的爱。你并不仅仅是因为先天的软弱或某种人格特征而爱上一个人，而是因为这是一种你被教导出来的病态行为模式，特别是从成长经历中，比如初恋，或者通过观察父母或身边其他人。所以这种经历和看到这些事情在你的脑海中创造了与特定感觉或反应相关的记忆根源。在这个场景中，这种感觉类似于我们所相信的。
is love. So for example, you know, say the first person you ever loved or dated was really inconsistent with how they showed affection or they would say things that contradicted their actions like saying that they loved you and then showing little physical intimacy or few acts that actually reflected that love. You know, they had it, they had the words for it, but they weren't able to kind of demonstrate that they did have these feelings. You know, but they call it love and you assume that's love. So in the future, when you have feelings for someone who reacts in a similar way, that's love to you. You convince yourself of the possibility that, you know, what is one-sided, quite obviously, it may actually be more nuanced. Like, no wonder you'll be attracted to people
就是爱。举个例子，假设你爱过或约会过的第一个人，在表达爱意时非常反复无常，或者他们说的话与他们的行为相矛盾，比如嘴上说爱却很少有身体上的亲密接触，或者很少有真正反映这种爱的行动。你知道的，他们嘴上会说，但他们无法证明自己确实有这些感情。你知道，但他们称之为爱，而你认为这就是爱。所以在未来，当你对一个有类似反应的人产生好感时，对你来说这就是爱。你会说服自己相信，那种明显是单方面的事情，其实可能更有细微差别。难怪你会对那些。
who are similarly withdrawn or in some cases just blatantly uninterested because, our brain is confused. It's programmed in some way to take ambiguous situations or situations even of ambivalence from another person, reflect back on those early experiences of love and match these experiences. You see those similarities and this kind of results in a cycle of feeling, of emotion, of care that is, you know, really unsatisfying and probably often one-sided because, well, you know, obviously you continuously fixate on people who are not interested. Love that is available, on the other hand, may be scary because it doesn't match your pre-existing and internal conception of what that feeling should look like. It kind of all comes
同样冷漠的人，或者在某些情况下干脆表现得毫不感兴趣的人产生吸引力，因为我们的大脑糊涂了。它在某种程度上被编程为：接受来自另一个人的模棱两可的情况、甚至是矛盾的情况，反思那些早期的爱的经历并匹配这些体验。你看到了这些相似之处，而这反过来又导致了一个真正令人不满意、并且往往是单方面的感觉、情感和关心的循环，因为，好吧，你知道的，你不断地去关注那些不感兴趣的人。另一方面，唾手可得的爱可能会让人感到害怕，因为它与你预先存在的、对这种感觉应该是什么样子的内部概念不符。这一切都归结于。
down to what we expect love and relationships to appear like, and this also connects to attachment styles, which I alluded to earlier, you know, getting stuck in the loop or repetition of consuming, you know, crushes and unrequited love, this kind of signals towards a fearful avoid and attachment style, which is in contrast with something like secure attachment. So let's break this down a little bit because I know attachment style gets talked about quite a lot, but what do they actually mean? Okay, so these four attachment style. So yeah, there are four attachment styles, one of which really relates to unrequited love. And then there's like kind of two that are in the middle and then there's one that's, you know, secure attachment.
归根结底，我们对爱和关系的期望是什么样的，这也与我之前提到的依恋类型有关，你知道的，陷入迷恋和单恋的循环或重复中，这有点预示着一种恐惧型回避依恋风格，这与安全型依恋形成了对比。让我们稍微剖析一下这一点，因为我知道依恋风格经常被讨论，但它们到底是什么意思呢？好吧，这四种依恋风格。所以，是的，有四种依恋风格，其中一种确实与单恋有关。然后中间大概还有两种，然后有一种是，你知道的，安全型依恋。
And that's kind of, we'll start with that one. Secure attachment is like the gold standard. Like if you want to pick an attachment style, you probably want to pick this one. You know, people with this attachment style, they have, basically, they have the ability to form secure loving relationships. You know, who doesn't want that? They're not afraid of intimacy. And they're able to depend on others without becoming, you know, totally dependent on that person. They're also better able to recognize when someone is not interested and remove themselves.
我们就从那个开始说起吧。安全型依恋就像是黄金标准。如果你想选一种依恋风格，你大概会选这种。你知道，拥有这种依恋风格的人，他们基本上有能力建立安全、充满爱的关系。谁不想要这个呢？他们不害怕亲密关系。他们能够依靠他人，而不会变得（你知道的）完全依附于那个人。他们也更有能力识别出别人对他们不感兴趣并抽身离开。
So it's kind of in the name, secure attachment style. These people, they're secure in how love is shown and their interpretations of love. And they can reciprocate but also receive. So next we have anxious. Attachment, this is marked by like deep fear of abandonment and clinging behaviour. And then we have avoidant or dismissive, which I think is probably like the shittiest or the second shittiest form of attachment style someone can have. So essentially what this attachment style means is you just have a fear of intimacy and you
所以这有点名副其实，安全型依恋风格。这些人，他们对爱如何展现以及对爱的理解感到安全。他们既能给予回应也能接受。接下来我们有焦虑型。依恋，其特征是对被抛弃的深深恐惧和黏人行为。然后我们有回避型或排他型，我认为这可能是某人能拥有的最糟糕或第二糟糕的依恋风格。所以本质上这种依恋风格意味着你只是害怕亲密关系，并且。
really just avoid getting close to anyone. People with this dismissive and ambivalent avoid. whatever you want to call it attachment style, they're more likely to have relationships whereby one party is just highly emotionally unavailable and they really prefer to be independent. Finally, we have fearful avoidant attachment style. And this is kind of a combination of anxious and avoidant attachment style. So people with fearful avoidant, they desperately crave affection, but they also want to avoid it at all costs. This is kind of why it's also known as disorganized attachment and it is
真的只是避免与任何人亲近。拥有这种冷漠矛盾回避（无论你想怎么称呼它）依恋风格的人，更有可能陷入这样一种关系：其中一方在情感上极度不可及，并且他们真的更喜欢独立。最后，我们有恐惧回避型依恋风格。这有点像是焦虑型和回避型依恋风格的结合。所以拥有恐惧回避型的人，他们拼命渴望affection（爱意），但也想不惜一切代价避免它。这也是它为什么也被称为混乱型依恋的原因，并且它。
associated with significant psychological and relational risks, you know, including a greater likelihood of a repetition or pattern of unrequited obsessions and unrequited love. And this style, it's developed in the formative years of a person's life and it's highly dependent on the responses and the nature of their bond with their primary caregiver, so usually their mother or their father. And the kind of bonding one has with their primary caretaker in their formative years goes on to define their attachment style. So someone with fearful avoidant probably had a parent or maybe an early
与显着的心理和关系风险相关，你知道的，包括更大可能重复或出现单恋的执念和单恋模式。这种风格是在一个人生命的成型期发展起来的，并且高度依赖于他们与主要照顾者（通常是母亲或父亲）的债券的反应和性质。一个人在成型期与主要照顾者建立的债券决定了他们的依恋风格。所以一个具有恐惧回避型的人可能经历过一个父母，或者可能是一段早期的。
relationship in which love was shown inconsistently and perhaps combined with violence or manipulation or emotional abuse. It may also then, the flip side of that may be that a lot of love bombing may have taken place in response. So the person, whether it's a first boyfriend or girlfriend or a parent, they withdraw love, they combine love with manipulation, and then they also overwhelm you with love when they feel guilty. So this person kind of learns to crave a love that is withheld, but it's also fearful of feelings that are obvious and apparent, because they indicate, you know, something else coming along and this kind of leads to this cycle of unrequited love.
关系，其中爱的表现是不一致的，并且可能伴随着暴力、操纵或情感虐待。作为回应，另一方面可能发生了很多“爱的轰炸”（love bombing）。所以这个人，无论是初恋男友、女友还是父母，他们收回爱，将爱与操纵结合起来，然后在他们感到内疚时又用爱把淹没你。所以这个人渐渐学会去渴望一种被扣留的爱，但也对显而易见、清晰可见的情感感到恐惧，因为它们暗示着（你知道的）别的东西即将到来，而这种循环最终导致了单恋的循环。
Okay. Obviously, this is not the only answer. You know, I've pointed out multiple times the universality of this experience. So there is another element, and it's not just those with fearful avoidant who would find themselves in this situation because this attachment style only makes up 4% of the population and if the statement I'm making it and I'm pretty sure I would be right like most people have experienced unrequited love you know if only 4% of the population is fearful avoidant this
好吧。显然，这并非唯一的答案。你知道的，我已经多次指出这种体验的普遍性。所以还有另一个因素，不仅是那些具有恐惧回避型的人会发现自己处于这种境地，因为这种依恋风格只占人口的4%，如果我所说的陈述是——而且我相当确定我是对的——大多数人都经历过单恋，你知道的，如果只有4%的人口是恐惧回避型，那么。
assumption that it's just because of your attachment style is obviously incorrect so another theory put forward is that unrequited love also has a lot to do with sunk costs and variable reward and you know, self-delusion as well. So if you like someone and you've built this image of a future with them or a fantasy in which they play a role, you have invested in the notion that they are a good person and someone who is worth your time. We often will also make the mistake of viewing everything they do with rose tinted glasses and giving their actions a lot more meaning than they probably deserve. So in this way, it's hard to break away from those feelings because of sunk costs. Essentially, we've already spent emotional capital on this person and time that cannot be recovered.
认为这仅仅是因为你的依恋风格的假设显然是不正确的。因此，提出的另一个理论是，单恋也与沉没成本、可变奖励（variable reward）以及自我欺骗有很大关系。所以如果你喜欢某人，并且你在脑海中构建了一个与他们共度未来的形象，或者一个他们在其中扮演角色的幻想，你就已经投入了这样一种观念：他们是一个好人，是一个值得你花时间的人。我们经常也会犯这样的错误：带着玫瑰色眼镜看待他们所做的一切，赋予他们的行动比它们可能应得的更多的意义。通过这种方式，由于沉没成本，很难摆脱这些感觉。本质上，我们已经在这个人身上花费了无法收回的情感资本和时间。
And if we have already, you know, metaphorically spent this emotional currency, we don't want that to go to waste. So we continue to pursue them either in our minds or externally because we want these sunk costs to have some output or a positive consequence for us. We don't want to lose that investment of time and energy. energy and thought that we've placed in that person. Secondly, when we are experiencing love that is unrequited, we also have to consider variable rewards. So the use of variable rewards, it's more of like an economic term, but it's often used in marketing,
如果我们已经，你知道的，在隐喻上花费了这些情感货币，我们就不希望这些付之东流。所以我们继续在心中或在外部追求他们，因为我们希望这些沉没成本能对我们产生某种产出或积极的结果。我们不想失去我们对那个人的时间和精力。以及我们投入的思考的投资。其次，当我们正在经历单恋时，我们还得考虑可变奖励。所以可变奖励的使用，它更像是一个经济学术语，但它经常被用在营销中。
but variable reward, it's used in gambling all the time because it's a pattern of reinforcement that is just scientifically proven to be the easiest way to get someone hooked to an activity. So essentially, your behaviour is rewarded on a schedule that is impossible to predict. So with gambling, you know, it's a best example because you just never know when you're going to get a jackpot or when you're going to get your money back. So in regards to relationships, for example, you know, you text someone and sometimes they leave you on red for like days.
但可变奖励，它一直被用在赌博中，因为它是一种被科学证明能最容易让人对某种活动上瘾的强化模式。所以本质上，你的行为会得到一种无法预测的时间表的奖励。所以在赌博中，你知道的，这是最好的例子，因为你永远不知道什么时候会中大奖或者什么时候能拿回你的钱。所以在人际关系方面，举个例子，你知道的，你给某人发信息，有时他们会晾你好几天不回。
And other times they're super-infused and they get back to you quickly. it's impossible to tell when each response may occur. So think about it, this in the case of unrequited love. You know, you have these feelings for a person, and occasionally that person may accidentally or maybe purposely reinforce them by hanging out with you, laughing with you, reaching out. And every time we try and pull away and be reasonable or realistic about our feelings, this variable reward schedule kind of stinks us back into it.
而另一些时候，他们超级热情，很快就回复你。根本无法分辨每次回复会在什么时候发生。所以想想看，在单恋的情况下。你知道的，你对一个人有这种感觉，而偶尔这个人可能会不经意地、或者可能是有意地通过和你一起出去玩、和你一起笑、主动联系你来强化这些感觉。每一次我们试图抽身离开，对自己的感情保持理智或现实时，这种可变奖励机制就会把我们重新拉回其中。
It's really difficult to escape. so we are really good at convincing ourselves of the things that we want to believe so self-delusion is like i kind of said is also a huge part of unrequited love you know the fantasy that one day this person might change their mind turn around confess their feelings it's really self-soothing for a lot of those different reasons that i've mentioned and often it is that person who is the most unavailable which is why we become hooked because it is their unwillingness to acknowledge you as a sexual or romantic partner that keeps you in a state of expectancy and longing. And this may especially be the case for those who are high achievers or those who have big ambitions.
这真的很难逃脱。所以我们非常擅长说服自己去相信我们想要相信的事情，因此自我欺骗就像我刚才所说的那样，也是单恋的很大一部分。你知道的，总有一天这个人可能会改变主意、回心转意、坦白他们的感情的幻想，由于我提到的许多不同原因，这真的很自我安慰，而且通常正是那个最不可及的人让我们着迷，因为正是他们不愿意承认你是一个性或浪漫伴侣，才让你处于一种期待和渴望的状态中。对于那些高成就者或有远大抱负的人来说，情况可能尤其如此。
You know, we are so often told that if it was easy, everyone would have it. So you want the thing that is most unattainable. So you subconsciously go after the least available person because to win them would be just the biggest hit of self-endorsement. So I think it really does go without saying there is just a lot of insecurity and an unrequited love. And the thing that really does keep us hooked is the notion that one day things could change. What we ultimately are seeking is love and to be cared for and acknowledged and seen. And love is a social value, perhaps one of the most important. No other idea or feeling in history is as revered as love.
你知道的，我们经常被告知，如果很容易的话，每个人都会拥有了。所以你会想要那个最难得到的东西。所以你会潜在地去追求那个最不可及的人，因为赢得他们将是对自我肯定的一次最大冲击。所以我认为这是不言而喻的，单恋中确实存在很多不安全感。真正让我们欲罢不能的是这样一种观念：总有一天事情会有所改变。我们最终寻求的是爱，是被关怀、被认可、被看见。爱是一种社会价值，也许是最重要的价值之一。历史上没有任何其他想法或感觉能像爱那样受人尊崇。
But the way this concept, this larger than life emotion is displayed in our culture is really contradictory. And I think it's what contributes to this admiration of unrequited love because there are these two distinct displays or depictions of love in our society that are so, so very different, but they're equally admired. And I think this is what contributes to these confused feelings around reciprocation. So firstly, we see love as this is a very different, as this stable, mutual, enduring force that it is comfortable and safe. This is often associated, you know, with long-term relationships and ideas of marriage and long-term couples. But on the other side of the coin, we are also taught to see love as this burning, electric desire, you're characterized by butterflies and intensity and full of longing and hope and you know just oh my god
但是这个概念，这个大于生命的情感在我们的文化中展现的方式实际上是矛盾的。我认为正是这一点促成了对单恋的这种崇拜，因为在我们的社会中有这两种截然不同但同样备受推崇的对爱的展示或描绘，它们非常、非常不同。我认为正是这一点造成了围绕回应的这些混乱感觉。首先，我们认为爱是——这是一个非常不同的——是这种稳定的、相互的、持久的力量，它是舒适和安全的。这通常与（你知道的）长期关系以及婚姻和长期伴侣的概念联系在一起。但在硬币的另一面，我们也被教导将爱视为这种炽热的、带电的欲望，其特征是蝴蝶效应（心跳的感觉）、强烈、充满渴望和希望，并且你知道，哦天哪。
it's almost painful like you just love them there's nothing you can do to control it and these two depictions they essentially make up our romance culture and it creates this like madonna whore complex but for love whereby you have to have both you have to be in pursuit of what is stable but also constantly in a state of this all-consuming electric feeling and our idea of love as a society is so fucked in that way, you know, it creates such an internal confusion because if you think about someone that you're obsessed with, this person, you know, you're consumed by them and you're consumed by this electric feeling and, you know, all this confusion and these butterflies and these uncertainty. And that's what you think love should be. And if only they
这几乎是痛苦的，就像你就是爱他们，你无力去控制它。而这两种描绘，它们本质上构成了我们的浪漫文化，它创造了一种“圣母-荡妇”式的复杂情结，但却是针对爱的，即你必须两者兼得。你必须既追求稳定的东西，又不断处于这种全情投入的带电感觉的状态中。我们社会对爱的看法就是这样操蛋的，你知道的，它造成了如此内部的困惑，因为如果你想到一个让你痴迷的人，这个人，你知道的，你被他们吞噬了，你被这种带电的感觉吞噬了，（你知道的）所有这些困惑、这些蝴蝶般的心跳、还有这些不确定性。这就是你认为爱应该有的样子。如果只有他们。
could see this or you could convince them, we could achieve that long-term. instability and comfortability that everyone wants. But that initial feeling of obsession, society teaches you that that's what love should look like. But I don't think it should. You know, unrequited love comes with a lot of resentment for that other person because they can never fulfill your fantasy because, well, firstly, they haven't consented to it. They may not even know it exists. You know, they may not even be aware, but we still feel anger towards them.
能看到这一点，或者你能说服他们，我们就能实现每个人都渴求的那种长期稳定性与舒适感。但最初那种痴迷的感觉，社会教会你这就是爱应有的样子。但我不认为应该是这样的。你知道的，单恋伴随着对另一个人的很多怨恨，因为他们永远无法满足你的幻想，因为，好吧，首先，他们没有同意这一点。他们甚至可能根本不知道它的存在。你知道的，他们甚至可能毫无察觉，但我们仍然会对他们感到愤怒。
And can that really be love? Can a feeling that includes so much resentment and anger and frustration, does that mean that unrequited love is real love? And I had a huge, huge discussion with my housemate around this. Actually, I think revealed like a lot of revelations about how we think about ourselves in the process, but that's kind of beside the point. What we came, the conclusion we came to is that, there are two broad strokes, and I'm talking very broad strokes, interpretations of love.
这真的是爱吗？一种包含着如此多怨恨、愤怒和沮丧的情感，难道这意味着单恋就是真正的爱吗？我和我的室友围绕这个话题展开了巨大、激烈的讨论。事实上，我觉得在这个过程中，这引发了许多关于我们如何看待自己的感悟，但那其实题外话了。我们得出的结论是，对于爱，大致上有两种方向的理解，当然我指的是非常宽泛的理解。
Firstly, there's the idea that love is a feeling and a distinct universal experience. It's something beyond our control. And on the other hand, we also see love as a performance, something that you need to work on and towards. So therefore, we do see unrequited love as, whether you see, sorry, whether you see unrequited love as real love, depends on whether you see love as a practice or as an emotion. Because if you see it as a practice, unrequited love can never be confused as true love. Because for you, love naturally needs two players
首先，有一种观点认为爱是一种感觉，是一种独特的普遍体验。它是我们无法控制的。而在另一方面，我们也把爱视为一种表现，一种你需要为之努力和付出的东西。因此，我们是否将单恋视为真爱，取决于你视爱为一种实践还是一种情感。因为如果你视其为实践，单恋永远不可能被混淆为真爱。因为对你而言，爱自然需要两个人的参与，
and there needs to be some mutual foundation on which to build this temple of care and reciprocation and empathy and giving. However, if you see love as an emotion as an all-consuming feeling of passion that arises naturally from some deep place in our conscious and our soul, then we can say unrequited love is true love, and it may even be pure love, because that feeling can exist in only one person and still be valid. It doesn't need to be reciprocated to still be felt.
并且需要某种共同的基础，来建立这座关怀、回报、共情和给予的圣殿。然而，如果你把爱看作一种情感，看作一种吞噬一切的激情，它自然产生于我们意识和灵魂深处的某个地方，那么我们就可以说单恋是真爱，它甚至可能是纯粹的爱，因为这种感觉可以只存在于一个人身上，却依然成立。它不需要得到回应也能被感受到。
I'm really skeptical to call it love, because I think calling it that really glorifies the experience, and we put other people on a pedestal, which is really problematic. We begin to confuse things and move away from what a healthy and stable relationship should be. Yes, you know, we can call it love if we want, but if it is unrequited love, the real thing. No, it's not. Love can only be felt at its deepest and most profound level, I think, when it is shared. And love is the process of gradually revealing yourself to someone, and although, you know, it can be all consuming as well and it's definitely incredibly natural and an organic feeling.
我其实很怀疑将其称之为爱，因为我认为这样称呼会美化这种经历，我们会把其他人奉若神明，这真的很成问题。我们开始混淆事情，偏离了健康稳定关系应有的模样。是的，你知道的，如果我们愿意，我们可以称之为爱，但如果这是单不单恋，算不算是真正的东西？不，它不是。我认为，爱只有在分享时，才能在最深邃、最深刻的层面上被感受到。爱是一个逐渐向某人展现自我的过程，尽管，你知道的，它也可能会吞噬一切，而且它绝对是一种极其自然和有机的感觉。
It also needs to be deliberate and must be mutual to be fully felt. But again, like kind of what I was talking with, there is no right or wrong answer. What we expect from love is based on what the relationships around us have taught us like our parents or our first relationship or our crush and that really determines how we view love. Okay, that was a bit of a rant. I think maybe it's time to wrap things up. Yeah, just I hope you enjoyed that discussion. Like I said, I really got into it.
它同样需要是有意的，并且必须是相互的，才能被充分感受到。但话说回来，就像我刚才说的，这没有对错之答。我们对爱的期望，取决于我们周围的关系所教给我们的东西，比如我们的父母、我们的第一段感情或者我们的暗恋对象，这真正决定了我们如何看待爱。好了，刚才有点唠叨了。我想也许是时候收尾了。是的，希望你们喜欢这个讨论。就像我说的，我真的非常投入。
I think just like having that time to sit down and reflect on so many past experiences that I've had, it really made me realize the own kind of calmic cycle of my relationships and, you know, feelings that I've had for others. And it was really therapeutic to actually read up about why this happens, to kind of give this highly irrational experience more of a logical tinge and more logical input and psychological input as well and yeah just breaking it down it was actually really helpful so i hope that you found it helpful as well if you are in a situation where you're experiencing love that is unrequited you have all my well wishes it's really shit it's really crap and it is really hard to break out of
我觉得，只是有时间坐下来反思我过去的这么多经历，真的让我意识到我人际关系中的某种业力循环，你知道的，以及我对其他人产生过的感情。读一读为什么会发生这种情况，真的很有治疗效果，给这种高度非理性的体验带来了一点逻辑色彩、更多的逻辑输入以及心理学输入，是的，把它剖析开来其实真的很有帮助。所以希望你也觉得这有帮助。如果你正处于一种经历单恋的境遇中，我送上我所有的祝愿，这真的很糟糕，真的很烂，而且真的很难摆脱。
So I hope, yeah, everything works out for you. I hope that, you know, I'm not going to hope that they're the one because they probably aren't. But I hope that you can kind of see the irrationality in it. Maybe this has helped you realize that and just move on, you know. It gets to a point where you kind of have to be realistic with yourself. Like, is this person ever going to reciprocate my feelings? Probably not. And it's time to kind of buckle up and move on to something else
所以我希望，是的，一切对你来说都会好起来。我希望，你知道的，我不会去期望他们就是那个对的人，因为他们大概率不是。但我希望你能某种程度上看到其中的非理性。也许这已经帮你意识到了这一点，并让你能够释怀，你知道的。总会到一个地步，你必须对现实点。比如，这个人会回应我的感情吗？大概率不会。是时候振作起来，向前看，去寻找别的东西了，
or just move on to being alone because it's kind of better than begging for attention or begging for feelings from someone who has no intention of giving them to you. You know, you have everything that you need in yourself. So, yeah, you don't need a man or a woman. It's getting very, like, new age, rantey, like, independent woman vibe. But you know what I mean. You can do it all on your own. You don't need to beg someone for the time of day or for a message back or for a reply.
或者干脆享受单身，因为这总好过向一个根本无意给你回应的人乞求关注或情感。你知道的，你自身拥有你需要的一切。所以，是的，你不需要男人或女人。这听起来变得非常像新时代、碎碎念、独立女性的调调。但你知道我的意思。你完全可以靠自己做到一切。你不需要去乞求任何人施舍哪怕一点时间，或者回一个信息，或者给一个回复。
So I hope you guys are all doing well wherever you are in the world. If you're in Canberra, we're getting through it. We only had eight cases today, which is so exciting. I never thought I'd say that. But yeah, I hope you guys are all staying safe. Remember to subscribe if you're listening for the first time on Spotify or Apple Podcasts and follow us on Instagram. Like I said, this idea for this one came from like an Instagram poll I did.
所以希望你们无论身在世界的哪个角落都一切安好。如果你在堪培拉，我们正在挺过去。我们今天只有八个确诊病例，太令人兴奋了。我从没想过我会说出这句话。不过是的，希望你们都保持安全。如果你是第一次在 Spotify 或 Apple Podcasts 上收听，记得订阅，并在 Instagram 上关注我们。就像我说的，这个话题的想法来自我在 Instagram 上做的一个投票。
So if you want to kind of contribute, it's up to you to what episodes. I get to look into. Yeah, definitely give us a follow. And thanks again for listening in. Take care of yourselves. And remember, the egg doesn't chase the sperm. Bye.
所以如果你想参与进来，由你决定我接下来要研究哪些节目。是的，绝对要给我们一个关注。再次感谢大家的收听。保重。记住，鸡蛋是不会去追精子的。再见。
2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience
2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用的情况下，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯顿。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析心理韧性、健身以及在瞬息万变的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。
in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84's big to me. I'm Sam J.
经历一些艰难困苦，你将以一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的姿态从另一端走出来。收听《2%》。就在 IHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方。《Look Back at It》播客。从 1979 年开始，这对我说是一个重要的时刻。对大卫来说，84年也很重要。我是萨姆·J。
And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick you here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. It was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会邀请你来到这里，剖析发生的历史，并试着理解我们是如何与朋友、同为喜剧演员的人以及最喜欢的作家一起幸存下来的。就像马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊 80 年代一样。那是一个疯狂的年代。那是一个疯狂的年代。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 Look Back at It。
Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kier Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having him with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcast,
嘿，最近怎么样，各位？你们正在收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖姆斯主持的《Learn the Hardway》。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历的，进行在任何地方都不太安全进行的坦诚对话，但你是在与一位懂行的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这么做。在 IHard radio 应用程序、Apple Podcast 上收听《Learn the Hard Way》
or wherever you get your podcast. This is an IHart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
或者在你获取播客的任何地方。这是一个 iHeart 播客。保证由真人呈现。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。